I think contemporary America deeply
mistreats the elderly in so many ways I
think ageism is alive and well in the
United States and our culture I think
the way we fund and staff nursing homes
is an absolute national disgrace it's a
it's an abomination and if it was really
known and understood we wouldn't be able
to to live with ourselves I think this
becomes a political issue very quickly
because we all tolerate this we're all
we're all complicit in the neglect
frankly the the engendered in culture
ated neglect that occurs not only for
the elderly but for anybody who is
physically dependent physically decir
eous ly disabled or or seriously ill and
dying it's as if they remind us of our
mortality and so we don't want them
around to a large extent frankly our
nursing homes today function as
warehouses that actually have a cultural
function though it's an it's an
embarrassing one of segregating people
who are ill infirm demented or just
plain frail and elderly keeping them out
of our sight we hire entry-level workers
we often don't pay those workers a
living wage there are far too few of
them to take care of the people who live
there and yet these are our grandparents
and our parents and our brothers and
sisters some places there are children
and it's so not okay that that really if
if many people could see what I've seen
and know what I know about nursing homes
you would think that that we would be
out in the streets demanding better care
to start with better staffing of the of
the nursing homes and and better support
for the people who work
I think people were working nursing
homes are are truly heroes in America
today I want to distinguish the systemic
neglect of nursing homes in the systemic
lack of support for nursing homes from
the people who work within them there's
some of the most committed people i know
but nursing homes are understaffed every
every study that's ever been done as
shown that there will understand in some
studies even governmental studies they
show that ninety percent of nursing
homes are understaffed and many many
residents of nursing homes are seriously
malnourished starving not because they
can't eat or don't want to eat but
because they need help in eating and
there is simply not enough aids to help
the residents of nursing homes eat at
mealtime in some studies it's it's a
ratio of 15 people who need help and
eating at meal times for each one aid to
help them eat this is a national
disgrace and you know unless or until we
can staff our nursing homes at levels
that are at least at least at a safe and
prudent level I would say we can't build
another highway we can't fix another pot
hole in the highways we have we can't
mount another even high-minded adventure
overseas in our military or anything we
have to take care of our grandparents
and our parents but we're not at this
point and I I don't understand and I've
been part of efforts in in New Hampshire
to bring this to the attention of
presidential primary candidates we have
huge support from the citizenry of New
Hampshire to make these issues a
priority please visit reclaim the end
org remarkable citizen initiative that I
was part of but we haven't done it yet
and notice it's not a top-tier issue on
in the presidential campaign but it is
an endemic issue and it gets even worse
i would say that we have a crisis that
surrounds the way we care for people and
the way people spend the last chapter of
their lives and way they died today but
unless we act these will be the good old
days
we will look back on on the way we cared
for people today we will look back at
today's nursing homes and they will in
retrospect look like luxury hotels we
boomers may may well yet live to see
real human warehouses from the inside
well the irony here is that you know
these are all correctable problems this
is not rocket science clinically or you
know from a health systems perspective
and it's and it's really not even that
expensive to do this well I mean when
twenty percent of Americans are dying in
icy use when fifty percent of Americans
are dying in hospitals when we spend as
much on the last part of the last year
of life as we spend on in the rest of
health care for any given individual at
least through their adult adulthood we
can care well for people through the end
of life we have to stop avoiding death
as if it were optional and begin to
actually look at what a package of
services and living situation patients
with their families need to live a full
and healthy life that doesn't mean we
have to play implant electrical
defibrillators in everybody it doesn't
mean that we necessarily have to provide
fourth and fifth and six late layer
chemotherapy to everybody but it does
mean that we have to staff our nursing
homes so that you know our parents and
grandparents have somebody to answer the
bell if they need to get up and go to
the bathroom or are wet you know have
somebody to help them eat it does mean
that families at home can get somebody
to to you know help them teach them how
to care for a perhaps an elderly frail
spouse maybe with memory loss or you
know pain from osteoporosis those sorts
of things we can do we do have to engage
more than just the paid health care
system though it has to be caring for
people through the end of life has to be
part of our families and communities so
this is this responsibility is really
shared I believe in in the communities
of our of our towns but also of our
neighborhoods of our buildings the
communities of our faith communities of
our service groups those sorts of things
this ought to be just part of what we do
for one another
and and not sort of somehow segregated
and and isolated
to the extent possible absolutely people
you know no one of the great
commonalities of the human condition is
that the large majority of people would
rather be at home during the last part
of life not everybody but you know into
the 75 to 80 percent of people say yeah
I want to be at home or in the home of
my family or friends I don't want to be
in some institution and so yes now it's
hard these days because people have to
work many couples are you know have two
jobs or three jobs between them just to
make ends meet to pay health care
insurance and the like so we have to
make provisions through insurance and
through policy to make that possible but
I don't think we will ever completely
avoid the burden that caring for one
another represents I don't want to sort
of somehow give the impression that some
change in policy or insurance is going
to just make this easy it will never be
easy but it doesn't have to be nearly as
hard as it is today
you know I've not traveled that much I
think the United Kingdom does it good
deal better than we do I think you know
Canada that our partners to the north
does it somewhat better than we do for
one thing in America many times people I
I meet and help care for are worried
about leaving their families with
financial burdens they they want to you
know get this over with more quickly you
know because I don't want to leave my
family with bills to pay and go through
all of our family life savings that's an
American source of suffering you don't
hear that from patients in Canada you
know they still worried about lots of
things pain and suffering and being a
burden to their family in other ways but
this notion that we're going to go
through all of our wealth and in fact
leave our family with debts boy that's a
big theme that I hear from patients
today and it is an American source of
suffering
you